Elon Musk is no longer the richest
person in the world he has seen his
wealth cut in half after he purchased
Twitter this year but he is by no means
short of cash he's still worth about 178
billion dollars musk lost the top spot
to Bernard Arnold the CEO of luxury car
maker car company LV MH you know as
Louis Vuitton musk's own car company
Tesla is having a rough ride at the
moment it's seen its stocks plunge 53
percent this year alone he had to sell
off billions in Tesla shares to fund his
takeover of Twitter pushing share prices
down further the car maker has also been
hit by recalls and slowing demand for
electric vehicles thanks to Global
inflation well days of erratic tweeting
by the chief twit that's what he calls
himself now his fueling suspicions that
Twitter has become too much of a
distraction for musk pulling him away
from Tesla at a time when the company
needs his attention
on Sunday musk tweeted a meme depicting
a scene from Lord of the Rings it shows
the white house chief medical adviser
Anthony fauci Whispering into the ear of
President Joe Biden saying just one more
lockdown my king something like that an
hour later musk would even further
tweeting my pronouns are prosecute fauci
musk if they are taking aim at a popular
practice of identifying one's gender
pronoun after one's name the Tweet also
alluding to a right-wing campaign to to
charge Dr fauci for his actions during
the pandemic basically saying that he
lied about the pandemic on Monday musk
tweeted this the woke mind virus is
either defeated or Nothing Else Matters
now that was after he was booed by the
audience at a David Chappelle Show in
San Francisco
amidst a lot of Silicon Valley Times
I want to pull in now Ethan Porter he's
an assistant professor in the school of
media public affairs at George
Washington University Ethan it's good to
see you again so I'm not going to ask
you to go inside the mind of Elon Musk
well yeah actually I am what do you
think what do you think he's trying to
do just let's look at the behavior here
um is is he trying to destroy the
company that he just spent 44 billion
dollars on
well I I don't think he's trying to
destroy Twitter what I I do think he's
done so far is sort of taken a
sledgehammer to the company he bought
and destroyed key components of it he's
fired thousands of people he's gotten
rid of The Trusted safety team
um why is he doing this
um I think there are two possible
explanations
um for his behavior the first is that
um he's a rich guy a very rich guy with
some really strong political views
um and all that we're seeing is somebody
who really believes what he's saying he
just happens to be one of the richest
people in the world so he can afford to
buy Twitter and express his views on
Twitter the other explanation that's
been bandied about is that this is all
strategic that what musk is doing is
trying to set up some kind of New Media
Venture with Twitter as a base that will
appeal
um to uh right-wingers in the United
States in the way that Fox News has
yeah and you know that may be the case
but at what opportunity costs I mean if
we just look at ads for example ads
account for nearly 90 of Twitter's
Revenue
um musk is risking a huge Exodus of
advertisers Tesla on the other hand
doesn't really spend any money on
advertising and it doesn't need to
um so is the problem that most doesn't
understand or that he doesn't care about
advertising here I mean it's almost like
he's hurting the baby that is already
very healthy
right sure he certainly heard Tesla by
doing this right Tesla's stock has gone
down its reputation has taken a hit
um and he's heard Twitter of course as
well because it's no longer a safe haven
for advertisers
um whereas before Twitter employed many
people who were responsible for giving
advertisers a safe environment for their
advertisements to appear uh musk has
totally got rid of that effort
um and advertising on Twitter is a risky
is a risky game
um I I think he ultimately doesn't
understand the advertising
um but I would even say more importantly
he doesn't view advertising as the
purpose of what he's doing
um so and this was clear from the
beginning when he took over Twitter he
immediately said I want there to be some
kind of subscription basis for this
allowing people to pay a fee
um that's what he wants he views Twitter
in its relationship to advertising in
the same way I think that he've used
Tesla's relationship advertising but he
doesn't really want it to define the
company well I mean I've wondered if he
actually understands what he was is
buying when he bought Twitter
Twitter's Capital are its users the
people that are tweeting all the time
and so he just paid you know 44 billion
dollars for himself basically do you do
you get the impression that he was aware
of that because everything he's been
doing you know you could argue he's been
alienated he's been actually estranging
himself from the capital that makes up
the bone marrow of the company
sure you know there is consensus in the
financial community that musk overpaid
for Twitter to begin with right so
before he annotes any of these changes
um people who who understand this Market
closely
um would say that he's overpaying
dramatically for it um and again sort of
gets back to the idea that there are two
possible explanations for this one is
look this guy just loves tweeting and he
has political views that he's tweeting
about and he's happy to sink the ship
the other view is there's some game here
that um he's playing
um and what that game is I think isn't
exactly clear
um and if anything if I had to guess I
would say the only sort of sophisticated
game he might be playing is constructing
an identity uh for a media company to
displace Fox News which you know is
tremendously profitable every year
Maybe
the fact that he is tweeting so much now
I mean if you go on Twitter now I mean
now it's become a daily event you go on
and you see that he's trending and you
want to see well but basically he's
doing what Donald Trump did when he was
the U.S president
um and when Donald Trump was President
he was tweeting all the time one of the
greatest systems was how can he carry
out the country's business how could he
carry out the business of president if
he's always tweeting well you could ask
Elon Musk the same thing you know how
can you run so many huge companies and
still have time to tweet
and I think the comparison to Trump is
an apt one
um I I think musk
um is intent on replacing Trump
um in the the nation's Consciousness and
the world's Consciousness for that
matter in using Twitter to do it
um it's possible and someone argue it's
likely he's wants to replace Trump just
because he likes Fame and celebrity
um there's really not much else to it
beyond that he wants to tweet and get
our attention because there's something
deeply gratifying for him about having
that attention
um that's certainly possible
um and you know in terms of his ability
to run the company and tweet as
frequently as he does
um yeah on that question I think it's
important to keep in mind that Trump uh
musk has historically delegated
um to people within each company
um and I think what we're seeing now is
a version of musk where he's a
figurehead a celebrity
um but you know I don't think his
running day-to-day operations at Tesla
um which I think in turn has spooked
investors because if he's not running it
who exactly is running it I think that's
a little unclear yeah there's been you
know there's a big Tesla Factory just
outside of Berlin here and a lot of
people have been asking here in Berlin
who is running the factory now that he's
busy tweeting all the time I guess we'll
have to find out who is that's a good
question Ethan Porter it's good to talk
with you we appreciate your time hope to
see you again soon thank you